Summer break has ended for many of us
and you are back at work or at school
and have many goals
you want to accomplish.
This might be a time
of motivational struggle.
You find yourself having trouble
doing your work,
exercising and eating healthily,
so you blame yourself
for not having more willpower
or for procrastinating too much.
According to behavioral science,
you can stop worrying
about your willpower
and quit calling yourself
“procrastinator.”
To stay motivated,
you need to change
your circumstances and outlook,
not your personality.
I'm Ayelet Fishback, a behavioral
scientist at the University of Chicago.
I've been studying what it takes
to be successful in goal pursuit
for over 20 years as an academic,
a parent and an immigrant.
I've also struggled
with motivation myself.
Let me offer a few interventions
that can increase your productivity
at work, school and beyond.
When monitoring progress,
looking back is often
the way to move forward.
For any goal, you can look back
at what you have achieved,
as well as forward
at what is still left to do.
When Minjung Koo and I
surveyed people standing in a long line
for an amusement park ride in South Korea,
we found that when they looked back
and saw how far they'd come,
they were more motivated to wait.
Back at the University of Chicago,
when uncommitted students look back
at the materials that they have already
covered for a final exam,
their motivation
to keep studying increased.
Beware of long middles.
We call it the middle problem.
We are highly motivated at the beginning,
we want to reach our goal
and we want to do it right.
Over time, our motivation declines
as we lose steam.
To the extent that our goal
has a clear end point,
as in the case of graduating
with a diploma,
our motivation will pick up
again toward the end.
In one experiment,
Rima Touré-Tillery and I found
that people literally cut corners
in the middle of a project.
We handed our participants
a pair of scissors
and asked them to cut out several
identical shapes with many corners.
They cut through more corners
in the middle of the task.
This solution?
Keep middles short.
A weekly healthy eating goal is better
than a monthly eating healthy goal
as it offers fewer days
to cheat on your diet.
It's hard to learn from feedback,
especially negative one.
Emotionally, failure bruises the ego.
We tune out, missing
the information feedback offers.
Cognitively, people also struggle.
The information in negative
feedback is less direct
than the information in positive feedback.
Whereas success points us
to a winning strategy,
from failure, people need
to infer what not to do.
To increase learning
from negative feedback,
try giving advice to others who might be
struggling with a similar problem.
Lauren Eskreis-Winkler, Angela Duckworth
and I found that when students,
job seekers and overweight individuals
gave others advice
on how to succeed in studying,
finding a job and eating healthily,
they were more motivated
to follow through.
Support intrinsic motivation.
You're intrinsically motivated
when you pursue an activity
that feels like an end in itself.
You do something for the sake of doing it.
If you wish you had a few more minutes
to finish your walk by the end of the day,
you're intrinsically motivated.
If you can't wait to go home, you aren't.
To increase intrinsic motivation,
start with selecting activities
that you enjoy pursuing.
A workout that you actually enjoy
is more likely to become
part of your routine.
Often people choose the wrong activity.
In an experiment, Kaitlin Woolley and I
asked people to choose
between listening to the song
“Hey Jude” by the Beatles
and listening to a loud alarm.
Seems like an obvious choice, right?
But the majority of the people
chose the alarm because it paid more.
Later, these people
regretted their choice.
Whether you look back, cut the middle,
give advice, support intrinsic motivation,
keep in mind,
success does not require
changing yourself.
To stop procrastinating,
modify your situation and outlook.
Whitney Pennington Rodgers:
Thank you so much, that was wonderful.
And I'd love to get into some
of the pieces that you suggested.
I think maybe one place to really start
is this idea of intrinsic motivation.
So could you talk a little bit
about intrinsic motivation?
What is it and why is it so important?
AF: Yes, intrinsic motivation
is critical for success,
because intrinsic motivation is the things
that we are getting
from doing the activity.
An activity is purely
intrinsically motivating
when it's an end in itself,
when it doesn't even make sense
to ask, "Why do I do it?"
I do it because I like doing it.
Well, when we try to motivate ourselves,
usually we have some goals that are not
purely intrinsically motivating.
Like, I need to finish
this project at work,
or I need to study for this class.
But still, there is some level
of intrinsic motivation.
It might be interesting, OK?
It might be fun.
It might be energizing.
And the more I feel like
doing this thing is an end in itself,
the more motivated people are going to be.
Now, let me also add that this
is not intuitive for people.
I've mentioned that when we ask people
to choose between two activities,
they went for the activity that paid more
and not for the one
that they were more likely to enjoy
and actually stick at that job later.
We see that there are two mispredictions.
People think that other people don't care
about intrinsic motivation
as much as they do,
and they think that they themselves
will not care about intrinsic motivation
as much as they end up caring.
And that can explain a lot
of the professional choices
that we make that are not ideal,
choosing the wrong workout regimen,
the wrong healthy diet for ourselves
because we don't quite appreciate
how important it is
to choose something
that is not only a means to an end,
but also feels like the end by itself.
WPR: Since we're talking about some
of the things you shared in the talk,
I'd love to also go back
to another piece you mentioned there,
which is just about negative feedback.
And you said that it's hard for people
to learn from negative feedback.
So could you talk a little bit more
about that and what sort of feedback,
how we can lean more into this,
the positive feedback as you describe?
AF: Absolutely.
So let me first say that I don't say
that there is not much
in negative feedback.
There is.
There are important lessons
in negative feedback.
However, it's hard to learn those lessons.
And it's hard, first, because emotionally,
negative feedback feels bad.
So we disengage, we tune out.
In one of the studies that we ran,
we found that people
don't remember the feedback
and don't even remember
their answer when it's negative.
They just disengage with a task,
they don't learn.
The other reason that it's harder
to learn from negative feedback
is much more cognitive.
It's not what we expected to hear.
And so, you know, if you did something,
expecting something to happen
and then it happened,
like, you kind of had a prediction
that was supported
with what later happened,
and you remember it.
When you get negative feedback,
it's often not what you expected.
And that can be a very confusing
experience for people.
And so they just don't learn.
It is cognitively a harder task
to learn from what's not.
It's learning by elimination.
So negative feedback is important.
There are often unique lessons
in negative feedback,
not to mention that if we don't learn
from negative feedback,
we're probably missing just a lot
of the information that is out there.
And so we need to be able to do that.
And I mentioned giving advice,
like, one of the strategies that we can
use to learn from negative feedback.
We also need to realize
that it is so much easier to learn
from positive feedback.
So, you know, whenever we can teach
someone through positive feedback,
they are probably
going to be more attentive
and better able to learn.
WPR: And you talk about that
in the way of giving advice
and that sort of, puts you in the space
of thinking positively towards someone
and maybe potentially receiving
more positive feedback yourself.
AF: Yes, and not only it puts you
in a position of power
and doing something
useful for the feedback,
helping another person,
it also forces you to think
about what you have learned, OK?
I know when we ask people to give advice,
in particular people that are struggling,
their immediate response is like,
"What do I know?"
"Why would you ask me?
I'm unemployed."
Well, not me, but the person
we are asking.
"I'm unemployed,
Why would you ask me
about how to get a job?"
And you kind of need to remind them,
"Well, you know how to get a job
because you've been doing that,
because you've been struggling."
And that forces the person to think
about what they have learned.
And so we're kind of tackling both
the emotional barrier to learning
and the cognitive barrier to learning.
WPR: We have a question here
from TED Member Mariam.
They ask, "How do we find
perseverance and grit
for the dreams and goals that take time?"
So how do we redefine the timelines
and bring that into our life?
AF: Oh, Mariam,
that’s a real problem, right?
Because ...
Because of the middle problem, right?
Because we are excited
when we start on something,
we are excited when we are
about to achieve an important milestone
or the ultimate goal.
And in the middle, we lose steam.
We lose our motivation.
And what I would say is,
break your goal into sub-goals.
Saving for retirement
is, you know, my ultimate example.
is really a hard goal
because you need to start
working on this goal
when you are so far
from completing the goal, OK?
When it seems like it's going
to be a different person,
that they don't really know that you would
benefit from pursuing this goal.
But you can think
about your annual savings,
how much did you save
this year for retirement,
not how much you're going
to save in total.
Exercising goal.
People talk about a weekly
exercising goal.
Now, clearly you do not just want
to exercise this week.
You will have that goal again next week.
Well, you set the weekly exercise goal
so it has a beginning and an end
and very short middle.
School is an interesting one
because it is actually easier
in higher education
where we break the year more clearly
into terms which are relatively short.
So there is not much of a middle.
And for kids, they have the long year,
which is kind of hard,
like, you start in September
so maybe you are excited on the first week
and then you will be again excited in June
when the school year is about to end.
But there's such a long middle.
Break it into a weekly goal,
a monthly goal,
something that has a short middle
and that is not long-term.
People are not good at pursuing something
where the benefits are very far.
WPR: I mean, in your research,
have you found that people of different
backgrounds, you know,
by age or gender or race,
that they experience
motivation differently
or that there are certain strategies
that are more helpful?
AF: There is a lot of research
on developmental effects.
You brought up several other variables
that just get me thinking
in like, ten different
directions right now.
So let me focus on the age.
There are some really interesting
developmental effects.
Self-control develops with age,
so the ability to put aside something
because there is something more
important that you want to do,
that's something
that develops into your 20s
and that suggests that maybe
there is another reason
why we should stop calling
our teenagers “procrastinators”
and blaming them for lack of self-control.
They are still developing it.
At a later age,
we see that as people's resources,
our physical resources are on the decline,
then there are new challenges.
And I briefly touch the idea
that you often need to find
a compromise between several goals,
and you need to think about how you pursue
several goals at the same time.
In research, we often look at this
in terms of finding activities
and we refer to them as multi-final.
They achieve more than one goal.
It's like, my example is
bringing lunch from home to your office.
This is healthier and saves you time
and it's often better food,
at least for me, OK?
So you achieve several goals
at the same time.
With older age,
often you need to give more thought
into how to choose activities
that allow you to interact
with other people
while also getting your daily exercise,
while also maybe enjoying
the fresh air outside,
just bringing more to the same activity
because maybe there's just less resources.
We also see that you need to drop
some goals in your life.
And you know, we always drop goals
when they are no longer useful for us.
So maybe you used to run
and at one point that didn't feel
right for your body,
you were able to do it and you
had to switch to a different exercise.
And people often have crises
when they need to switch
from one goal to another,
but goals need to be dropped.
WPR: Well, TED Member Ron
asks a question about progress.
They want to know,
“What do you do if you look back
over the last week or month,
and you're disappointed
in the progress you've made.
How do you move forward
from that feeling?"
AF: So you can choose whether to look back
or to look forward, Ron, right?
At any point, it's completely up to you.
You can look at what you achieved.
You can look at what is still missing.
And you can kind of try to see
what’s motivating for you.
If you are disappointed
with the progress that you have made,
now you have the choice
how to frame your disappointment.
Is it lack of commitment
or lack of progress?
Now let's think about it.
If it's lack of progress,
then, you know, your
disappointment is healthy, OK?
That suggests that you should do more.
You have not made progress,
so let's just double the effort,
let's work harder.
If your interpretation
is lack of commitment,
well, that's not great,
because now you assume
that you did not make progress
because probably you cannot make progress
and will never make progress.
And we can see how that kind
of thinking is not very healthy.
And so what we find in studies
is that when people frame past failures,
or some setbacks as lack of progress,
that increases motivation.
"I did not exercise yesterday,
I should definitely exercise today."
When they think
about this lack of commitment,
this is where we see problem.
"I did not exercise yesterday.
I might not have it in me.
Maybe I will never be able
to be the person that I wanted to be."
It's up to you.
The framing is something
that you can choose.
WPR: Well, one member asks
about procrastinating for fear of failing.
Do you have any tips
for dealing with that?
AF: Yes, there is some literature
on what we call “self-handicapping.”
And self-handicapping
is an interesting phenomenon.
It's like the student that purposely
did not sleep the night before the exam
so that if she doesn't do well,
she can blame the circumstances.
She can say, "Well,
I was too tired to do well."
And we see that sometimes people do that
because they're afraid to try
because they are afraid about what failure
might mean for who they are.
I think that as a society,
we should probably just have healthier
relationships with setbacks.
There is a lot of work
in motivation science
about how to learn from failure,
how to learn from a setback.
Probably the basic thing is to understand
that there are lessons in there, OK?
That that was not a wasted experience.
That made me the person that I am,
that enriched me somehow.
Think about it.
If you try to cook something,
and you burn the dish, well,
you don't have dinner, but you learned
something about cooking, OK?
And think about what you have learned.
WPR: Yeah, yeah.
Well, I mean, I'm sure
we have a lot of people on
who are part of teams or,
you know, working in groups
and TED Member Colm,
they ask about how you can motivate
and unstick a group of people, a team.
They lead multiple medium-sized teams
and sometimes can sense
that they're feeling a lack of motivation
among the team members.
AF: Yeah, well, the larger the team,
the larger the problem with motivation.
Basically, this is what
we call “social loafing.”
When there are many people
that can do the work,
then we all tend to leave
the work to someone else.
And we see these effects
really increasing very rapidly
with the size of the team.
So there will be less social
loafing in a team of two people
and much more when it's a team of ten.
We know that since basically
Ringelmann, a French
engineer, ran studies,
so in some studies with men pulling a rope
at the beginning of the 20th century,
as you can imagine,
when several men pull a rope together,
they invest less effort,
than when they do it by themselves.
And we see it in studies all the time.
The simplest solution:
make sure that you can identify
people's contributions.
That it's not one pile of contribution.
We know how much each person did.
We can say that, Whitney,
this is how much you did,
and Ayelet, this is how much you did.
We even see this with donation.
So, you know, sometimes you
give money to charity
and it all goes into some
like, large bucket,
and your 10-dollar contribution
feels like a drop in the ocean.
Other times, some organizations
and charity campaigns,
they make sure
that they list each donation.
So you can see
that Whitney gave 10 dollars,
and this is much more motivating
and likely takes care of the problem
with having a large group of people
working together toward the goal.
WPR: I think sort of,
in the same bucket of thinking
about positive and negative ways
to motivate in groups,
TED Member Hahnsol asks,
from an individual perspective,
about the difference between positive
and negative motivation.
You know, "I want to do this"
versus "I need to do this
to avoid trouble."
Is there one that's better than the other
in terms of keeping a person motivated?
AF: I would say that yes.
"Do" goals are better than "do not" goals.
Approach goals are better
than avoidance goals.
What do I mean by that?
When you invite people to bring
more positive thoughts to their lives,
this is much easier
than when you tell them
not to think about something negative.
Push away negative thoughts.
When you invite people to bring more
healthy foods to their their diet,
that's easier than removing
foods from their diet.
"Do not" goals are problematic,
in particular when we think
about the long run,
when we think about doing things
more than today and this week.
There are two reasons.
One reason is that this approach,
these "to do" goals,
tend to just bring to mind
what you need to do,
whereas the "do not" goals tend to bring
to mind what you should not do.
So if you think that you should
stop doing something
or stop thinking about something,
how do you know if you are successful?
You ask yourself, "Do I still have
this forbidding thought?"
Well, by asking,
you bring it to mind, OK?
The other reason is just reactive, OK?
When I tell you that you should
not eat something,
this is exactly the thing
that you want to eat.
Like, don't look to the right.
Well, everybody's now looking
to the right, right?
Let me also say that the one big
advantage of avoidance goals,
of "do not" goals,
is that they seem urgent.
If I tell you that you should
stop eating red meat,
then it seems more urgent than
let's say, eat more green vegetables.
And so avoidance goals
have their place in our life,
they seem urgent.
Now, the question was also about like,
needs vs. wants,
which somewhat overlap
with the approach/avoidance,
but not totally.
There are things that we feel
like we're absolutely required to do
like, we might feel
that a high school degree
is like, "I need to do it.
This is absolutely a must."
Whereas, a higher education,
"I want to do that."
Like, that might be an extra bonus.
That might be a wonderful thing to do.
And then we find
that there are different emotions
that are associated
with these different goals.
So, you know, whereas success on a need,
successfully pursuing a need
is more likely to be associated
with feeling relieved
and "Oh, I did this."
Success on a "want" goal, an aspiration,
is more likely to make us proud
and make us feel that we have done
more than we should have done.
WPR: TED Member Jo-Neal is just curious
about sticking to a schedule
and how important that is
to reaching a goal
and tips for doing that.
AF: Yeah, thanks for asking
about schedule.
Many people like to have a "to do" list
and kind of, going by the "to do" list.
Just a personal anecdote.
When I was debating
the many covers for my book,
one of them has a "to do" list
that was proposed by the publisher.
And I said, “Well, I can’t have
a ‘to do’ list on the cover
because I don’t recommend ‘to do’ lists,
and I don’t write about ‘to do’ lists.”
And so you kind of know how I feel
about sticking to your "to do" list
and the schedule.
It's good to write down
what you want to do.
And I actually suggest
drawing your goal system
so your different goals
and relationship between them,
whether they help or suppress each other,
just that you understand your priorities.
But then the idea about goals,
the beauty about goals,
is that they get you going.
They they give you purpose,
they make you intrinsically motivated,
they make you engage,
you get to connect
to other people over goals.
You get to feel good.
Whether you have actually
reached all these goals
on your "to do" list?
Often, who cares, OK?
It doesn't really matter.
It matters that you made progress.
So I'm not a fan of strictly making sure
that you checked everything on the list.
WPR: We’re wrapping up here,
and actually there was just one question
as a follow up from before,
which was just about, if not "to do" list,
what's sort of an alternative
to that approach?
AF: A goal system.
Now a goal system is basically
you writing down the main goals
that you currently want to pursue, OK?
So it doesn't need to be
in your entire life,
but in this time, in the year,
like what are the things
that are important for me?
And it could be like, in terms of
my social relationship, work,
projects at home,
what are the things
that you want to achieve, OK?
And then what are the activities
that serve any of these goals
and understand the relationship
between these goals,
between these activities,
being particular on the look
for activities
that help you achieve
several goals simultaneously.
These are the things that you want to do.
WPR: And just as we're wrapping up here,
if there's one thing for folks
to take away from this conversation,
what do you feel like
is the big piece of advice
that everyone should apply to their lives?
AF: You motivate yourself
by changing the situation
and the framing of the situation.
It's not about fantasizing
that you will be a different person.
It's really about changing
what surrounds you and how you see that,
how you find your outlook
of what's around you.
This is basically the lesson, by the way,
from the social sciences,
so this is not just for motivation,
this is how we explain people's behavior
in terms of the situation
that they are responding to.
And it's very applicable
to staying motivated.
WPR: Thank you so much, Ayelet,
for joining us today.
AF: Thanks, everyone, for having me.
Thank you, Whitney,
for all these wonderful questions.
[Want to support TED?]
[Become a TED Member!]
[Learn more at ted.com/membership]